the fight over the Senate's fake border
security bill is heating up with
Democrat Senate Majority Leader Chuck
Schumer now arguing that US troops will
be fighting in Ukraine if Republicans
don't open up the southern border and
fund a bunch of random Wars we're at the
turning point in America this bill is
crucial and history will look back on it
and say did America fail itself why is
it crucial well if we don't Aid R uh
Ukraine Putin will be walk all over
Ukraine we will lose the war and we
could be fighting in Eastern Europe in a
NATO Ally in a few years Americans won't
like that if we don't help Israel defend
itself against Hamas that Perpetual war
will go on and on and on if we don't
help humanitarian Aid to the starving
Palestinians in Gaza hundreds of
thousands could starve and the Border
everyone who said it's chaos a speaker
you just saw speaker Johnson he said
it's chaos we have to do something
legislative a few months ago but what
has happened in answer your to qu your
question so this is crucial for America
it's a turning point history is going to
look over our shoulders and say Did We
rise to the occasion let me distill all
that Gobbledy down into one sentence
what Schumer is saying is open up your
border flood your country with future
Democrat voters and give us money for
Foreign Wars that don't involve vital
American interests or we will send your
sons to die in
Ukraine that's what he's saying it's not
so much a political prediction as it is
a threat they tried the libs tried
simply lying to us they tried pretending
that this bill was a border security
measure then we found out it wasn't most
of the funding has nothing to do with
the border and the few little bits of it
that do relate to the Border actually
open rather than close the border we
don't need any legislative solution here
the president and the Secretary of
Homeland Security could simply enforce
the law and they refuse because they
want to keep the Border open that's why
they're they're trying to pass a bill
that will open the Border even more so
they tried the carrot that didn't work
now they're trying the stick open up the
Border or we'll send your sons to die
just the latest proof of something that
we've been saying for a long time you
know I hate to say that I Told You So
for the Democrats open borders and mass
migration are priority number one they
see this as the key to permanent
political hegemony and they will not
allow something as trivial as pesky
voters from keeping it from them I'm
Michael NES this is the Michael NS
[Music]
show welcome back to the show Tucker
apparently interviewed Putin it's kind
of crazy
a lot of people are preemptively
attacking Tucker for it we will get to
it later on in the show first though we
got to turn our attention away from the
Kremlin we got to turn our attention
away from Ukraine and from the southern
border we got to turn it to ice spice
because I had this question you got you
got our political leaders just forcing
stuff that nobody really wants down our
throats weakening our country throwing
open our borders and and Americans a lot
of them are going along with it how did
we become so weak how did we become so
servile and I think ice spice actually
demonstrates part of the way that
happened she has a new song out it's
called you you ain't the Shi T
parentheses f a
t Miss spice take it
away what you not even the I'll be
going
I'm breaking
hearts Qui but I'm
quier but i'mi could be but
I'm keep going that's all we okay that's
all we need actually this reminds me of
a line from Plato as the musings of ice
spice often
do from I
think I forget exactly which book of
Plato's Republic he writes quote musical
training is a more potent instrument
than any other because Rhythm and
Harmony find their way into the inward
places of the Soul on which they
mightily fasten imparting Grace and
making the soul of him who is rightly
educated graceful or of him who is
ill-educated
ungraceful which do you think this does
Alan Bloom great U humanist and a great
conservative writer of the 20th century
he he in his book closing of the
American mind
had a chapter on how rock music is
really bad for you because it it arouses
the Bas passions and rock music is like
brumms compared to ice spice this is
music for Animals this the music itself
is for Animals
just just jiggling around smacking
yourself as ice spice is doing but the
lyrics also are for Animals the
animals you think you're the Shi t b c
but you're not even the f t
you you think you're rich but I'm richer
you think you're quick but I'm quicker
and it goes on and it's so disgusting
and crass and vulgar I can't get it out
of my head it's so overthe toop in its
vulgarity that I find it funny and I
actually have texted it to a few people
because I can't get over it but it's
it's very depressing because this is
popular music this isn't just some
little track that came out from some
unheard of musician on the internet
somewhere as a joke this was debuted at
some big Spotify event this is a woman
who's done collaborations with Taylor
Swift other prominent musicians I I'm
not as familiar with the ice spice
U but she's a very popular musician and
this is the kind of slop cultural slop
that goes out there for I'm sorry to say
we the increasingly unwashed
masses this is it and and when this is
bouncing around your head well it's not
really bouncing around your head it's
bouncing around your loins it's bouncing
around your your lower passions but what
what Plato says is true this surpasses
and subverts your reason so you're not
reasoning about this when you sit and
listen to some classical music or
Gregorian chant or something it's much
more intellectual it's much more
rational because you're you're not
immediately aroused and bumping and
grinding and bouncing and twerking and
doing all the stuff that ice spice is
doing but this kind of music make makes
you behave less like a rational soul and
more just like an animal you know just
kind of bouncing around and thinking
about bodily functions and fluids and
movements and uh if if we treat
ourselves and educate ourselves to be
like animals if this is the kind of
stuff that forms our soul then we're
going to be ruled like animals then
we're going to be ruled like a bunch of
pigs and cows and sheep which is
increasingly how our political order
works
now uh speaking of our political
order president
Biden has just come out and uh explained
a conversation that he had uh this was
at the beginning of his presidency with
uh French president franois mitterand
who died in 1996 you know right right
right after I was elected I went to what
they call a G7 meeting all the NATO
leaders it was in it was in the south of
England and I sat down and I said americ
America's back and meeran from Germany I
mean from France looked at me and
said said you
know what why how long you back
[Music]
for then and he said uh he said to me
hey Jack he said uh you want to pass
that cant I said I don't have enough
butter there pal and uh we were we were
going swimming we went swimming down
there by the playing banjo and we where
am I this is the sort of stuff that old
people do in the final months of their
lives I don't I'm not intending to pick
on Biden particularly or or to be all
that provocative just anyone who's ever
had a grandparent Decline and die knows
that this is the sort of stuff they do
they confuse not just dates not just you
know this past Tuesday with two Tuesdays
ago they confuse decades they confuse
people
they can fuse figures into epochs it's
not as though uh meand in France was the
previous president you know it was meand
and then it was Emanuel macron who's the
current president of
France the guy was President of France
in the 80s through the early to mid 90s
and then he died a year after he left in
1995 he died in 1996 and what does Biden
know it's just like your your
grandparents uh on their way out they
would talk about you know Aunt Sally who
died 20 years prior as though they were
just talking to her yesterday I'm not
saying it's the six sense I'm not saying
he's actually talking to dead people but
he certainly is confusing whole epochs
whole eras of politics and the crazy
thing is that man might get
reelected does not help me sleep well at
night you know it does help me sleep
well at night Helix right now go to
helixsleep.com I've had my Helix for for
years now and I love it it is extremely
comfy in fact I just got a bed a big boy
bed for my little toddler who is moving
out of his crib guess what kind of
mattress I put in it you guessed it baby
a helix Helix is the gift that keeps on
giving Helix harnesses years of
extensive mattress expertise to offer a
truly elevated sleep experience the
Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models each tailored
for specific sleep positions and
firmness preferences nervous about
buying a mattress online while Helix has
a sleep quiz matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress go to helixsleep.com
kwes to take their two-minute sleep quiz
and find the perfect mattress for your
body and sleep type your mattress will
come right to your door for free Helix
has a 10-year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free it's good
enough for me it's good enough for my
little buddy my eldest son it is
definitely good enough for you Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free dream pillows for my listeners
visit helix sleep.com
kwes this their best offer yet it won't
last long helixsleep.com
with Helix bitter sleep
starts now
shockingly that man might get another
term as president because the
establishment is willing to do anything
to get rid of Donald Trump the latest
setback for Trump comes from an appeals
court which has just ruled that
President Trump does not have
presidential immunity from prosecution
of alleged criminal acts related to 2020
election interf fence and blah blah blah
Insurrection nonsense this was decided
by the US court of appeals for the
District of
Columbia uh this pertains to special
counsel Jack Smith's election
interference case so you know Biden has
sent his goon Jack Smith to try to
destroy the former president the leader
of the opposition because especially
these days all the polls are showing
that Donald Trump would beat Joe Biden
especially in the swing States so
Biden's got to got to get rid of him and
Trump has argued hey man I was the
president I've got some immunity here
you can't just go after your political
opponents like we're a tinpot Banana
Republic dictatorship and the US court
of appeal says yes we can actually and
we are going to do that specifically to
you Donald Trump so the Trump team will
certainly appeal this to the Supreme
Court and there are two things I'm
certain of when that appeal goes up to
the Supreme Court the two things I'm
certain of are that the Supreme Court
will want nothing to do with this the
Supreme Court does not want to decide
this case and the second thing that I'm
quite confident of is that the Supreme
Court will not be able to avoid
it I I got to meet Anton and Scalia when
he was alive obviously I'm not like Joe
Biden I don't talk to dead people and I
met him twice when I was a student and
on at least one occasion maybe both
times Bush Vore came up when the Supreme
Court in 2000 decided the presidential
election and he said are are you people
still complaining about
this enough about this you think that
the Supreme Court wanted to decide the
200 an election we didn't want any part
of it okay but no one would decide it so
we became a mockery at the United States
we couldn't conduct a presidential
election we're supposed to be the
greatest democracy in the world and so
because the legislature wouldn't deal
with it and the states couldn't deal
with it the Supreme Court had to deal
with it we ruled the way we ruled and
get over it but they didn't want to and
I'm sure they don't want to now but
likewise I'm equally confident they
won't be able to avoid it because if the
Supreme Court declines to hear this case
then the Supreme Court is getting
involved if the Supreme Court wants to
hear the case the Court's getting
involved but if they don't hear the case
and they uphold the appell at decision
then that's the very same it's the
Supreme Court
saying in America today you can
prosecute the leader of the opposition
in America today we're going to become a
tinpot dictatorship go for it would be a
stamp of approval to Joe
Biden and to all of the Democrats who
have been trying to sty president Trump
even from running since
2015 so they can't avoid it the the
question is not will they rule on this
one way or the other they're going to
they'll rule either by their silence or
in a formal opinion the only question is
how are they going to decide now
speaking of removing people from office
there is an effort underway to remove
DHS secretary Alejandra mayores who is
the figurehead of this open border
crisis and some Republicans want to
impeach him and the Very the very
principled
reasonable moderate Republican are
saying that this is a bad idea they're
saying that mayorcas mayorcas might be
terrible you see but he has not
committed an impeachable offense and
therefore because I'm a very principled
conservative I'm not going to become
like those Democrats you see I'm not
going to actually wield any political
power or threaten the liberal
establishment no no no I'm just going to
lose with dignity yes that's right
follow me on the bill Crystal podcast
next week and it's just all completely
ridiculous
there is a very very good legal argument
for impeaching DHS secretary mayorcas
very good argument there's an even
better historical argument for
impeaching mayorcas and there is an
ironclad political argument the Heritage
Foundation actually has a good piece on
this I encourage you to read the whole
thing mayorcas feigns ignorance he says
quote it's very difficult to make sense
of it it's very difficult so I don't try
to make sense of it I'm doing my work
I'm doing my work and making sure it
doesn't distract me from
it doing your work you're emphatically
not doing your work your work is to
secure the Border you are not only
failing to do that you are intentionally
not doing that you're shirking your
responsibilities so what's the legal
background here to impeach someone they
need to have committed treason you know
or high crimes and misdemeanors other
high crimes and misdemeanors so does
this count well it it would seem to
count you know there's only been
one uh cabinet secretary who's ever been
impeached in American history this was
Secretary of War William bellnap in
1876 and what was he impeached for among
the charges
included uh were that he quote
disregarded his duty as Secretary of War
so you're not supposed to impeach
someone for Mal administ ation just for
being kind of
incompetent but historically speaking
now we're going back 150
years the one time this has happened the
one President we have is that a cabinet
secretary was impeached for actively
disregarding his duty in his cabinet
position furthermore the house Judiciary
Committee outlined about 50 years ago uh
when impeachment is proper and
impeachment according to them is proper
when an official exceeds the powers of
his office
or behaves in a manner grossly
incompatible with the proper functions
and purpose of his office or employs the
power of his office for an improper
purpose so even according to that the
1970s
surely the and that was obviously a
Democrat house surely mayorcas qualifies
he is abusing his power his his behavior
is grossly incompatible with the proper
functions of his office the function of
his office is to secure the Border
that's that's largely his
and he's not doing it he's intentionally
not doing it he is abusing his power by
releasing these illegals into the
interior of the country he's certainly
exceeding the powers of his office and
he's seeking to imply the powers of his
office for an improper purpose flood the
country with foreigners checks every
bucks and then then you get to that's
the legal and the historical basis but
then you get to the political basis we
now use not we the Democrats now use
impeachment in this country as just a
kind of a referendum on leaders that
they don't like
they impeached Donald Trump twice but
the first time they impeached him in
2019 they impeached him for acting quote
in a manner contrary to his trust as
president and subversive of
constitutional government to the great
Prejudice of the cause of Law and
Justice and to the Manifest injury of
the people of the United States now that
is so absurdly broad especially when
we're talking about impeaching a
president of the United States it's
ridiculous it was ridiculous then but if
that's the new president can anyone
could Chuck Schumer even argue could May
orcus himself argue that he has not done
that is that he's not acting in a manner
contrary to his trust as the Secretary
of Homeland Security and subversive to
constitutional government he's
intentionally breaking the law and
encouraging hundreds of thousands
millions of people to break the law as
well basic laws like who gets to come
into the
country impeach mayorcas there's no real
argument against this good legal case
stronger historical case airtight
political case and yet there are two
Republican congressmen who don't want to
do it Tom mclin and Ken
Buck Tom mcclin says quote the only way
to stop the Border invasion is to
replace the Biden administration at The
Ballot Box swapping one leftist for
another is a fantasy solves nothing
excuses Biden's culpability and
unconstitutionally expands impeachment
that someday will bite Republicans so
this is the
classic squish argument I look I'm I'm
sympathetic to Tom mlin talk I don't
want to unfairly malign him but he's
just flat wrong here this is the this is
this the worst refrain of the squishes
and they say
well listen if we in any way push back
against Democrat Injustice today then
hypothetically in the future they might
do it to us even though they're already
doing it and they've been doing it for
years they if we fight back at all they
the Democrats in the future might
continue to do the very thing that they
are doing to us right now can you
imagine boy that would that's sure scary
isn't
it oh uh it's scary that it's happening
now it's not a hypothetical and I wish
we would do anything about it he says
it's it unconstitutionally expands
impeachment I I I agree I wish
impeachment were narrower than it is but
it does it's not unconstitutional it's
not ahistorical it's not illegal it's
not no it's
just it satisfies all of those
criteria historical legal politically
wise you got to do it the other one's
Ken Buck he's
retiring and he's also come at against
the impeachment efforts unfortunate I
hope I hope we can flip mcclint talk
back because there're only three
Republicans that determine the House
Majority it's not like this is some 20
member majority it's a three vote
majority so you lose two of them okay
well now you lose one more and it's over
and the the Democrats are are very good
at unifying the Republicans are very bad
at unifying but if if we if we can't
unify to take a vote that is largely
symbolic that is totally justified by
history and politics and law to stop the
issue of our time the defining political
issue of our time that is mass migration
the complete blowing up of our borders
and and an
invasion from foreign countries if we
can't do that what's the GOP good for
what are we going to do we're going to
cut taxes a little bit more maybe in the
future or something okay what are we
going to do what's the GOP going to do
build violins that we can fiddle while
the country Burns okay fine if guys if
the Republican party can't unify on hey
maybe let's stop the mass Invasion that
Democrats are using to create a
permanent electoral majority then just
wrap it up man wrap it up and let's get
a new political party okay a lot of
Republicans are going to be tempted to
walk and when you want to walk
comfortably you got to check out G defy
right now go to G defy.com Cod
mk30 the number 30 good Footwear is
about more than fashion what you wear on
your feet Matters To Your Health comfort
and well-being choosing Footwear that
provides support for your daily routine
is very important thanks to G defi shoes
it's easier than ever and they're
extremely fashionable I love these shoes
G defi offers a patented Soul
construction meticulously designed to
bring the pep back to your step but much
as I love how good they make you feel
and how how much better they are just
for your day-to-day activities they look
phenomenal I currently have two pairs of
these shoes I've got these great Oxford
shoes with broing very nice and
traditional and I've also got running
shoes I never thought that I'd willingly
get some running shoes but these are
really sleek and nice and I just ordered
some loafers too you should get these
they look great your feet deserve more
than just another pair of shoes right
now use code mk30 for 30 bucks off
orders of $150 or more at G defy.com gdf
y.com promo code mk30 for 30 bucks off
your purchase of 150 bucks or more
experience the miracle that is g ify
where Comfort meets Innovation yes or no
is not just a show it's the daily wire's
number one party game with 200 cards
filled with titilating topics and the
ability to play up to nine people at
once you can put your knowledge of your
friends and family to the test go to
dailywire.com shop to get yours today
also if you like me will seize any
opportunity to ponder aliens the
moonlanding conspiracy theories then get
the yes or no conspiracy expansion pack
and you can re enact the episode that I
just had with my friend Matt Walsh so
you don't think that that humanity is
10,000 years old but you think that view
is more insightful to quote CS Lewis no
don't quote what quote yourself okay to
quote Michael NS to quote Michael NS
Earth is to quote Michael NES one time I
read CS Lewis and what he told me no I'm
quoting me the human species is blank
years old roughly 10 so you think so yes
is the answer no
[Music]
no
with over 110 new cards you can find out
even more about your friends and family
and judge their stances on the most
hotly contested conspiracies in American
Life get the expansion pack at
dailywire.com
shop because the original game was not
controversial
enough there are still a lot of
centrists in the G op that's how Tom
mlto and Ken Buck can come out against
impeaching mayorcas that is how one of
the two remaining presidential
candidates in the GOP Primary can
endorse this horrific Senate open border
Bill uh which one is endorsing it
obviously it's not Donald Trump that
would be Nikki Haley the one part I like
about this bill is I like that it
strengthens the Asylum chart the Asylum
requirements that's very important we
haven't had that and we need that the
part that I don't like about the bill it
doesn't require remain in Mexico which
is very important at keeping them from
coming on us soil in the first place and
I don't like the 5,000 limit we don't
want anybody to come in we can't say
only when 5,000 people have crossed the
border they need to stay there they need
to figure this out they need to adjust
it amend it in any way that they can and
they should not leave DC until they get
us a border bill and no we are not
waiting until the general election to do
this and it's irresponsible to say that
Congress has to wait until a general
election because Trump is worried that
he's going to lose there's a lot of
reasons we got to worry Trump's going to
lose but you don't sacrifice National
Security to do it okay I have a
disagreement sandwich with Governor
Haley here which is I agree with the
part you said in the middle which is
yeah 5,000 is way too many we don't want
anyone we want to stop it we don't want
any illegal aliens coming across the
border I disagree with the first part
she says this strengthens the Asylum
requirements I I don't think it does I
mean I I'm not calling Nikki Haley a
liar I just think the bill is very
dishonest and it says lots of things
that are very deceptive and but one of
the things that it does is it empowers
the Secretary of Homeland Security to
unleash a ton more people into the
country based on rather dubious Asylum
claims and so I just I just don't buy
that part at all and I really disagree
with that that third part which is when
uh Nikki says that we need a legislative
solution we we have a legislative
solution already we've had it on the
books for a long time it's current
immigration law the reason there is a
crisis is because the Biden
Administration refuses to enforce the
law that is already on the books this
why is why this this Senate deal this
big compromise was a joke from the start
the Democrats are obviously not
negotiating in good faith they're
currently violating the law and so what
do we think we're going to pass a new
law and then magically that's the one
they're going to enforce they're not
going to enforce any of them they want
open borders and so they're they're
going to enforce the provisions of this
so-called border security bill that
further open the Border I'm sure they're
going to gleefully Implement those but
they're not going to implement any more
border security measures Democrats have
been playing this game on us since the
1980s really since the 1960s but but
certainly since the Reagan
Administration they've said okay give us
some more IL
aliens that we can turn into voters and
we'll give you more border security and
every single time they promise it we
give them amnesty we give them more
voters we give them more foreign
Nationals in the country and they don't
give us any more security so I just
think it's it's either woefully naive of
Nikki here or or she's courting a
position that is in favor of more
migration now I I trust her on the
second part I think she's being sincere
that she wants less illegal migration
well then you can't support support this
bill just absolutely crazy to support
this bill now Nikki is more inclined to
intervene overseas and Chuck Schumer
wisely tied the the open borders parts
of this bill to funding for the wars
that they want to be fighting so uh you
know I'm I'm not surprised that Nikki
who's a little more hawkish than some of
the other GOP would be inclined to vote
for that but the whole premise I think
is just false we don't need any new
legislative solution we need to enforce
the old legislative solution which the
Democrats won't do which proves that
they're not going to force the new one
either what a what a joke now as for
Nikki's position here I think it's
politically very smart I think it's
really smart I think it had the disantis
campaign been
wiser they they would have recognized
the fact that Nikki Haley recognized
early on which is there's only one other
Lane in this race you got Trump and he's
running in the Trump Lane so the only
lane that the Trump opponent can run in
is the anti-trump lane and to be in the
antitrump Lane you're going to have to
attract the support of the moderates the
centrists the an never trumpers some
Democrats who have become disillusioned
and Chamber of Commerce the GOP
establishment that's it you know it's
not no knock whatsoever on Nikki Haley
that's her Lane and she's running in it
but I I don't see how that lane takes
you the distance it it makes you a
really strong well not even that really
strong it makes you the number two makes
you very clearly the number two but I
don't think it takes you all the way to
the nomination
what's amazing here is you've got the
the two GOP Presidential candidates are
on opposite sides of this bill Trump
actively calling Senators to kill it
according to reports Nikki Haley
supporting it or supporting some version
of it and then you got RFK Jr a Kennedy
who was running as a Democrat and he
realized the Democrats were obviously
going to cheat him so now he's running
as an independent but he's he's a
lifelong liberal he just came out
against the bill Bobby Kennedy Jr said
the new Senate bill is a disaster we've
already SP spent $13 billion on this
proxy war in Ukraine requesting an
additional 60 billion when we have so
many problems at home including
inflation and the Border crisis is
reckless no more money for Ukraine until
we have a secure border a booming
economy and pay off some of our $34
trillion of debt this is a consensus
issue America doesn't want to continue
fighting this war in Ukraine there's no
strategic Vision here it's it's unclear
to most Americans what we get out of it
most Americans are not all that gung-ho
on the expansion of NATO and it's not
just because they're you know kneejerk
rube idiot isolationists or whatever we
hear from The Establishment that's also
the opinion of Henry Kissinger of Daniel
Patrick moan of George Zimmerman who
wrote the uh Long Telegram of uh who was
the other
one Sam nun of all these great cold
Warriors okay and uh it it's the opinion
of most Americans too even even
Democrats even people like Bobby Kennedy
same thing goes for Mass migration most
Americans don't want more migration okay
okay most
Americans certainly don't want more
illegal immigration but when you look
into polling on even legal migration
most Americans think we have too much
legal migration when you talk when you
actually get down to the nitty-gritty of
numbers it's too much we got too many
people coming in we got to cut it out we
don't assimilate
them that's how it goes now we'll see
therefore on this issue who's going to
win it's not going to be who's going to
win the Republicans with the Democrats
it's going to be who will win the people
or the minority of political Elites and
that that question remains open now
speaking of critics of the medical
establishment such as Bobby Kennedy Jr
this is probably my favorite story of
the whole day HHS not DHS not the
homeland security department but the
health and human services department was
just asked to produce the evidence that
it has
[Music]
that with you
now speaking of things that are real and
tangible we got to turn to Birch gold
right now Tex nolles to 9898 98 between
election season coming later this year
North Korea testing missiles and Iran
increasing its aggression there is a lot
of global instability as we plunge into
the new year how do you protect your
family in the midst of all this chaos a
great place to start is by protecting
your savings it's not too late to invest
in gold with Birch gold group today
unlike many other Investments gold is
often viewed as a safe haven investment
during turbulent Times by providing a
hedge against inflation and economic
uncertainty Birch gold will help you
convert your existing Ira or 401K into a
tax sheltered Ira in gold and it doesn't
cost you a penny out of pocket while
diversification does not eliminate risk
entirely Birch Gold's experts can help
you manage and reduce providing a more
resilient foundation for your financial
well-being I would encourage you to talk
to one of their trusted experts today
teex nolles kW to 989 8.98 for a free
info kit with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau countless fstar
reviews and thousands of happy customers
strongly encourage you to check out
Birch gold today text nolles kW to 98
9898 claim your free info kit and
protect your savings with gold nolles
kwes to 98
9898 my favorite comment yesterday is
from the drummers Workshop Norms music
did I pick the drumers workshop normous
music for my favorite comment yesterday
as well is that two days in a row very
impressive comment is remember Target
the boys can't be the
girls he for Black History Month Target
apparently confused wbb de boy and
Booker T
Washington
deboy can't be the girls do you get it
do you get it I get it it's very funny
now speaking of medical
experts this is this has been a day it's
been a day of
laughing and a day of weird sex stuff
and those two things are related we can
laugh or we can cry I I laugh at the ice
spice
song I laugh at this article I I
laughed I'm laughing out loud right now
haaha this is from NPR headline I
can't
headline masturbation abstinence is
popular
online doctors and therapists are
worried men are not being total wankers
all the time oh uh oh that's no good
that's they're not men are not being
total weirdo creep demoralized losers uh
that's not good for us in the liberal
establishment here are some highlights a
very very long piece NPR is very
concerned that men are not committing a
shameful and degrading action here
here's a highlight Derek doesn't look at
noof fap content anymore noof fap is
apparently a website that encourages men
to not do gross degrading things to
themselves uh and he feels comfortable
with the amount of porn he watches more
recently he got off his ADHD medication
he realized it had been causing his
erectile dysfunction not pornography the
pornography was totally fine how dare
you
bch our exalted pornography now 24 he
looks back at his time with these ideas
and wishes he hadn't spent so much of
high school stressed out about
masturbation you know
someday according to NBR according to
the Liberals someday you're going to be
on your death ped you're going to be
looking into the eyes of your
grandchildren well you probably won't
have grandchildren because you're a
total sterile wanker but if you did
you'd be thinking about your
grandchildren and you'd be your
potential grandchildren and you'd be
looking back on your life and you'd say
you know if there's one thing I wish
it's that I had masturbated more you
know I just if only ah all those years I
spent you know reading
books working at soup
kitchens spending time with my family
what a waste I could have been looking
at porn and pleasuring myself oh such
regret that I feel uh NPR goes on said
many people in no fap spaces believe
they're addicted to porn but the word
Addiction means different things to
different people okay we live we live in
a world where we we deny the moral
significance of all sorts of bad actions
right everything's an addiction now oh
you can't blame me i' I've got an
addiction to this drug or to this
alcohol or to this food or to I've got
sex addiction or work addiction
everything's an addiction every Vice is
pathologized except for looking at porn
and doing weird sex stuff by yourself
that's not no well hold on here we need
I think we need to be a little bit more
specific here there is no official porn
addiction diagnosis in the United States
a condition called
hypersexuality which included a
subsection for pornography was
considered and rejected by the
psychiatrists who compiled the
influential Diagnostic and statistical
Manual of mental disorders there's no
porn's great the DSM which in recent
years has downplayed the fact that if
you're a dude who thinks he's a chick
you're the the DSM which of course
always included that uh has recently
tried to downplay it a little bit the
DSM which has taken out all sorts of
other sexual deviances in in recent
years because uh of political
correctness now they're saying no no
porn man all these psychologists they
say porn's totally
awesome as an adult unlearning much of
what Derek took in from masturbation
abstinence forums has been a long
process sometimes even bringing him to
tears he's not angry but thinking back
he just wants kids like he was to be
cautious about whom they trust I could
have been happy during that time rather
than stressed out and anxious yeah trust
us trust us the liberals who are
encouraging you
to be a fat loaf to do a bunch of drugs
to watch porn all day long and then to
cut your genitals off the moment that
the poor the porn convinces you you're
the opposite sex that trust us trust us
as kids hey come on out to the NPR van
in the parking lot we got cookies and
puppies out there and a lot of porn too
oh man this is the Babylon be could have
written this article it would have been
indistinguishable from the actual
article published on NPR that M take
away from which is they want you to be a
wanker they want you to be sterile they
don't want you to have kids they don't
want you to be productive they don't
want you to be verile at all they don't
want you to be in control of yourself
that's ultimately what it comes down to
they want you to be totally enslaved to
your low passions your appetites they
want you to be hooked on porn and drugs
and everything else they don't want you
to be in possession of your rational
will because then if you are they can't
control you and what they want to do is
control you that's the way it goes
now Tucker Carlson is in Moscow that's
kind of weird there was some chatter
about this I didn't mention it on the
show yesterday because it was still a
little bit unclear Tucker has now
confirmed it he flew to Moscow to
interview Vladimir Putin we're in Moscow
tonight we're here to interview the
president of Russia Vladimir Putin we'll
be doing that soon almost 3 years ago
the Biden Administration illegally spied
on our text messages and then leaked the
contents to their servants in the news
media they did this in order to stop a
Putin interview that we were planning
last month we're pretty certain they did
exactly the same thing once again but
this time we came to Moscow
anyway we are not here because we love
Vladimir Putin we are here because we
love the United States and we want it to
remain prosperous and
free I can't wait to watch it I Tucker
is already being preemptively criticized
for the interview already there are
political cartoons about how he's a
Putin puppet and a Putin stoe and and
whatever but I don't really see why we
would preemptively attack him for for
even conducting the
interview plenty of American journalists
have interviewed Vladimir Putin he's not
the first one to do it think Megan Kelly
interviewed Vladimir Putin barbaraa
Walters interviewed Vladimir Putin I
don't plenty of people have done it over
the years now in the past the United
States was trying to have some sort of
rap rosmont with Putin they were they
were trying to encourage Putin to
liberalize they were
and I guess now we're not doing that I
guess now we're saying Putin is the
worst guy ever and they're calling him
Hitler 2.0 and what so I understand why
the liberal establishment doesn't want
any more interviews with Vladimir Putin
but that's not good good enough for me
the liberal establishment is wrong about
a ton of
stuff so I just I'm not I'm not going
into the interview thinking Tucker did a
great job or just as he says I love
Vladimir Putin or I don't know I don't
know if the interview is going to be
good or bad I don't have any particular
sympathy for Vladimir
Putin but I do know that the liberal
establishment lies to me all the
time so I'll keep an open mind I'll be
listening isn't it aren't the Liberals
the ones who always tell us knowledge is
Power Man
keep an open mind collect all the
information we can't suppress it and but
then the moment you've got a major world
leader who's been a world leader for 20
plus years now we can't listen to him it
seems kind of crazy to me along with the
federal government spying on a
journalists text messages and the
current leader of the opposition's text
messages Donald Trump and then trying to
throw him in prison I don't know I I'm
sure Putin has done all sorts of
terrible things just like Shian ping has
done all sorts of terrible things but is
our government becomes increasingly
tyrannical and
irrational I'm certainly interested in
hearing from non official non liberal
establishment approved sources all right
that's our show there will not be a mem
room segmentum here I've got to run out
very quickly but there will
be an all access today so if you're not
a member go to dailywire plus make sure
you subscribe I'll see you there I'm
Michael nlls this is the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
a